[Musique]
bonjour bonjour je t'ai vu me regarder
depuis la
[Musique]
rue j'imagine que tu vis seul je te vois
jamais avec
personne ce sont tes parents
ils sont mors j'avais à peine 12 ans
j'essaie d'écrire sur eux en ce
moment comment ça se
passe c'est
bizarre
salut
salut est-ce que c'est
réel ça te paraît
réel Adam est rentré à la maison notre
fils c'est incroyable tu étais un petit
garçon et tu ne l'ai
plus c'était il y a longtemps c'est pas
pour ça que c'est plus
facile je me suis toujours senti comme
étranger dans ma
famille tu avais peur en
permanence tu passais ton temps à fuir
tu te
rappelles pardonne-moi de pas t'avoir
consolé quand on avait
besoin il suffit pas
grandchose pour revivre le passé et
ressentir à nouveau les mêmes
[Musique]
émotions tu crois que tu pourrais
l'aimer je me suis toujours senti
seul mais là c'est
différent toi et moi
ensemble seul au
[Musique]
monde